a person's strengths are often their
biggest weaknesses and so that also
means that their weaknesses can be their
strengths so me I am weak in all those
ways that I listed I am weak but I don't
accept that I don't accept that I am
what I am and that that is what I'm
doomed to be no I don't accept that I'm
fighting I'm always fighting I'm
struggling and I'm scrapping and I'm
kicking and clawing at those weaknesses
to change them
to stop them some days I win some days I
don't but each and every day I get back
up and I move forward with my fists
clenched toward the battle toward the
struggle and I fight with everything
I've got to overcome those weaknesses
and those shortfalls and those flaws as
I strive to be just a little bit better
today than I was yesterday